[Music]
the gaucho he is the gaucho word it will be
unequal that
the peak comes to sell huacho and guaxupé it is when
the animal like this na and dies the mother he is
raised without a mother
[Music]
then the person realizes that it was from maule your
name is  well he is a calf 1 and
he is raised in wood and he stays there the name
we call guayas because he is
alone he has no mother he has no father
[Music]
and there in rio grande in uruguay in
argentina the land areas are very tense
it was a farm campus in a big
campaign and there they created a cabal the
cattle and the gaucho and it was usually in
taking care of that part of the bankrupt of the
horse
he went out in the morning normally alone and it
's just him riding the horse and and he stayed
all day  there in the countryside they would have lunch and they would do
a marathon or vary some meat for
the fado I would take it in the suitcase to eat at
noon because it gave love it's a long way to
go back girl will come back but since she's
in and that's where this guy is selected
from gauchos  who always scream alone
because the user
they are  as always in life alone does not
do
and then with time there was a foie
and the gaucho was also the gaucho uruguay from the un
in argentina gaucho knot in brazil and rio
grande do sul for having this affinity
very similar to that of the gaucho
they are a gaucho only to help  very much like
a wolf on earth where the value of the
place he is created in that place
he loves a lot of classy place and they also
stay a little lp identity room
with his nature with things and that
's that thing of him being alone 71
the volunteer leaves him  he's a
very, very calm person
at stage a
[Music]
only when he's worried on the flagstones he's
provoked and there's a fighting animal, team
fights and they're not very afraid of any case
of mdf brave gaucho
[Music]
the man